what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm
actually going to be reacting to donovan
sharps
womanknees 101. before i start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification bow that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos um the funny thing is i'm
actually having him on my channel next
week so it'll be interesting to see if
um
if i agree with like the what she says
versus what she means no way i'd ever
sleep with him okay oh wait let me
this is on 2x okay
[Music]
there's no way i'd ever sleep with him i
want to [ __ ] him
remember what i said about women trying
to convince wait
is that is that what it's supposed to
mean
say it again okay there's no way i'd
ever sleep with him i want to [ __ ] him
remember hey
what i said about women trying to
convince you of something knowing
they're lying
this statement is the quintessential
example of this in action
no it's not
the more she tries to convince you that
she doesn't want to sleep with him the
more she wants to in fact she needs
another context sleep with him he's a
nice guy
i do not want to [ __ ] him
this is what women say about he's a nice
guy yeah i would agree with that one i
agree with the second one men they don't
want to [ __ ] without hurting his
feelings remember women are never
straight up about anything least of all
their sexual preferences the nice guy
statement is glorified sugar coating i
just love the energy around him
i totally want to [ __ ] him
i just love i've never said that
i just love the energy around him okay
women just never come right out and say
i wanna [ __ ] him that makes her look
like a [ __ ] so they find something
obscure about a guy and play that up as
an excuse to be around him so when her
friends ask why is amanda around dave so
much they can answer with oh yeah she
loves his energy
he's husband material i'm not attracted
to him
i'm trying to think if i've ever
i'm not attracted i feel like no i feel
like he's husband material is more like
he's someone i could see myself settling
down with um
but
i don't know i wouldn't i wouldn't put
that one i'm gonna just say yes or no
quickly woman isn't sexually interested
in a man but sees that he can provide
her with a good life after she's had her
fill up random dick she'll call that man
husband material and make sure he hears
about it this keeps him in her orbit
until she's finished with her host face
he's a good
guy but not for me
you i'm not turned on by him
this falls true
to the same category as the nice guy
phrase same circumstance same tactic
he's cocky arrogant and [ __ ]
i'm definitely attracted to him
girls just love
ah
sometimes i'll give that one sometimes
love to pretend that douchebag character
oh my god ellie
my doctor heuristics like arrogance is a
huge turn off
their biology can't help but be aroused
by men who act like they're god's gift
to women
simply pointing these characteristics no
there's a difference between confidence
and douchey
like confidence turns into douchey very
fast and douchey is not attractive
which is like a form of arrogance in my
opinion i mean she has already imagined
[ __ ] him
i hate you
i love you and i want to [ __ ] you
there's a thin line between love and
hate as the saying goes and it's wrong i
agree with this i think the worst
emotion you can get from a girl is
indifference
if she hates you there's still emotion
there 100 true a woman cannot hate you
if she has never loved you so when a
woman says this to you or about any
other man it is an open invitation to
[ __ ] her and blow your load in her
face which by the way is exactly what
she wants
i don't want to ruin our friendship
i don't want to [ __ ] you
true
this is another sugar coating tactic it
also means that you are in the dreaded
friend zone and once you're there you
are never getting out i'm not sleeping
with you tonight i secretly hope you'll
try to [ __ ] me
this one is a go
no
go to [ __ ] test that women like to
deploy when they feel themselves
becoming aroused by you when a woman
says she's not sleeping with you tonight
it means two things number one she's
thinking about having sex with you which
is why she said it and number two she
wants you to try to [ __ ] her
no no okay no i'm gonna give you
sometimes
it's because the guy is being super
pushy
and you just want to make it clear like
look
we can like hang out or do whatever but
we're not we're not doing anything so i
actually i think that's a misconception
because there's been times i've gone on
dates like obviously before my boyfriend
um
where like the guy i can just tell like
that is on his mind that's what he wants
to do and just to be like look like
chill out or just like hanging out
um but i feel like it someone it's funny
watching this mannose fear content has
made a lot of [ __ ] like make sense that
guys have like said to me over the last
couple years this is also another sludge
shield tactic she doesn't want you to
think she's a [ __ ] but trust me when i
tell you she will open her legs the
minute you start to escalate i speak
from personal experience i will never
talk to you again
i will [ __ ] you whenever you want
this one is
i've never said that to someone
probably same category as i hate you
she's trying to convince you she's
completely done with you but she knows
she's not in actuality she's also trying
to convince herself i love you to death
i don't like you like that
this is what women i love you to death
what we say to all of the betas in their
orbit thing isn't that didn't you say
that like
what's this what's his girlfriend's name
oh my god i talked to her she was so
cool
um
devin
didn't devin like write you a letter and
say that she loved you so much and all
this stuff
i love you to death is it different
because it's to death no they will never
sleep with if a woman ever says this to
you you will never [ __ ] her you're oh
okay okay okay this is a girl that like
oh okay okay i agree now i agree this is
a girl you're not sleeping with okay
other than me
i do not want to [ __ ] you yeah true this
is friend zone talk gentlemen girls
don't [ __ ] their brothers guys this
statement is a death sentence to your
sexual conquest of her yeah let her go
if she says that let her go
i will always love you
i will never
[ __ ] you again
again women are never straight up
because they hate giving bad news and
they're allergic to confrontation what
she's really saying is i'll never sleep
with you again but i'll always love you
and that's just as good right there are
over six i'll never sleep with you again
why yeah she's saying i'll always love
you like it's not a breakup talk so yeah
i would imagine
interesting it's so interesting when i
think about how the whole manosphere is
just trying to understand women
i don't know
that was a fun video though i want to
react to more of those let me know in
the comments um if you guys like these
type of reactions don't forget to
subscribe i'll talk to you guys next
time